I'm Virginia Trimble and professor to
physics and astronomy at the University
of California Irvine when I joined the
department in 1971 I was the youngest
member I'm now the oldest member of the
department still on full active duty
there are three issues one is objects of
study the second is technology and the
third is the kind of person who's likely
to succeed let me take these backwards
when I started most papers had one
author you had an idea you worked on it
maybe worked with one person maybe the
idea came from an advisor maybe you had
an idea and passed it on to someone else
but most work was done by one or two
individuals now a large fraction of the
work is done by enormous teams that was
first the case for the particle
physicists at CERN but it's now true for
LIGO and for supernova searches and the
upcoming large synoptic survey telescope
and many other things second is the
technology we've benefited a great deal
from Wars it's been claimed that every
technological advance in the world
always came from battle I'm not sure
that's true but we did benefit
enormously from World War two radar and
World War two rockets radar gave us
radio astronomy rockets gave us x-ray
astronomy and eventually getting into
space and actually bringing back samples
and the third thing is the the popular
topics to investigate and when I first
started doing this most people worked on
stars and many of did spectra of stars
and measured abundances and positions
and proper motions and radial velocities
stars are now not very very fashionable
many people now work on the whole
universe or the formation of the very
first galaxies or planets orbiting other
stars and so forth does the the popular
objects have changed and of course we've
added neutron stars and black holes to
the inventory and quasars and pulsars
and gamma-ray bursts and fast radio
transients which we still don't have all
understand
so lots more objects more ways of
studying them and requirement for a
different kind of person I don't think I
particularly good I don't think I know
I'm not a particularly good team player
one possibility and this is entirely
stolen from a senior physicist and there
may or may not remember who but he said
if he could go ahead a hundred years he
would not ask specific things like have
you made fusion work or do you have
quantum computers he would ask what if
physics still exists what are the
principal branches of physics and what
do they do